And I know this is so politically
incorrect to say, but
Islam is incompatible with what is
called Western civilization today. Okay,
bottom line, in short. Why?
Well, because it basically codifies and
deifies, because it gives it a
theological framework, everything that
the West rejects. Okay? So, in
definition, what's happening when
European nations bring in large Muslim
populations and tell them, "Yeah,
practice your religion here. Here's your
mosques. Here's your Qurans." How can
How else can we help you? What they're
doing is introducing a parasite in the
host society. All right? Again, I know
this is very inflammatory type language,
but hear me out. So, Islam, first and
foremost, again, how is this
antithetical to Western norms? Is
inherently tribalistic. Okay? And why do
What do I mean? Do I mean it's tribal in
the sense that, you know, they're just
close to their own race or ethnicity?
Well, of course, that's there. But, what
I mean is, above and beyond that, it's a
doctrine. And I've talked about this
particular doctrine, cuz it's the most
important one, I think. It's actually
more important than jihad, because it's
what actuates jihad. It's the It gives
it the sort of intellectual and moral
fuel. And it's the doctrine of, in
Arabic, al-wala' wal-bara', which you
can translate as loyalty and enmity.
And, long story short, Islam commands
Muslims through the Quran to disavow all
non-Muslims, to have hatred for them in
Quran 60:4,
Sura 60:4,
and to ally with and help fellow
Muslims. Okay, well, that's tribalism
101, but this is deified now, okay?
Which gives it a stronger tone, a
stronger motive. You're doing this not
because it's a primordial way of living,
it's because God wants it. And it's a
primordial way of living. So, the two
fit with each other. You're already born
that way, and you want to live that way.
People naturally are tribal, and now you
find out God and God, Allah, demands
this of you. Okay? So, that's the number
one reason that Islam does not
assimilate very well in the West, okay?
And but what are the other There's so
many other things. It's Islam is
inherently patriarchal, okay? And I
personally have no problem with
patriarchy, but that's very bad in the
West, right? Cuz the West is very much
against patriarchy. In Islam, sex roles
are clearly defined and they're not, of
course, in the West, okay? But then
there's more obvious things, you know,
in Islam you have to war on and even
kill the blasphemer and the apostate. So
there's no freedom of religion, which
supposedly exists in the West, or at
least for every religion except
Christianity. Of course, Islam has an
inherently built-in thing of
supremacism. This is everywhere in the
Quran, you can read about it. Quran
9:29, fight the people of the book,
which are Jews and the Christians, until
literally it says they they feel
submitted and subdued and pay tributes
feeling humbled, okay? And there's a
whole doctrine about how to do that, how
to keep them humiliated, right? So it's
very supremacist and it's very
exploitative
of the non-Muslim. That same Quran
verse, 9:29, talks about, again,
extracting tribute, which is called in
Arabic jizya. And of course, if you
didn't know this, all the Muslims in the
West who take welfare and aid and all
that, they see it as jizya, okay? This
is our rightful due from the infidel.
Okay, so we're coming to the West and
we're going to take our due, you
infidel, pay us cuz we're really your
overlords. And some of them say it
flippantly and jokingly. There was that
one very famous cleric, Choudry, I
think. I think he's in jail now,
finally, who boasted about how he has
many wives and many children in the UK
were all supported by welfare. And he
said, "Well, yeah, it's jizya. They they
owe us this, right?"
So, taken together, it makes sense why a
person may not want Islam in their
country, Western country, okay? Because,
like I said, you're introducing a sort
of parasite into the host body. It
contradicts. The two contradict and
one's going to feed off the other. That
is why we're even having this
conversation. And of course, we can get
into the history, which is what I really
like to talk about, about how for 14
centuries Islam has been waging war on
the West, which was primarily Christian.
All those Muslim nations today of the
Middle East were primarily Christian.
From all the ones in the Middle East and
Egypt and all the way to modern-day
Morocco, Iraq, Turkey. Okay, so it was
conquered. It's been a long-term goal to
conquer the rest of Christendom, which
was the final bastion was at Europe,
which fought back severely and violently
to maintain its civilization and its
culture and its religion until recently
when it's been it doing the exact
opposite to kill itself, right? So
that's where we're at. And as a final
point, which I just remembered,
since we're talking about the case
against Islam, I think it was in 2015
when a rather gory video came out of
ISIS, the Islamic State in Iraq and
Al-Sham, in Iraq and Syria, and in
Yemen, cuz that's where the video was
taped. A video came out on February 15,
2015, the famous video where 21
Christians, 20 who were Coptic
Christians, if you don't know, that's my
background ancestry, I'm Coptic, and one
was from Ghana, African man. And it's
they're in the orange jumpsuits with
ISIS behind them and simply because they
would not convert to Christianity, we
have the story of them. They stood
behind them and carved their heads off,
okay? So that's another reason as a as a
simple reminder. And actually, any day
you look at on the calendar, you will
find these sorts of things, Islam being
featured in them. I'm showing you and
I'm giving you the the case against
Islam amongst non-Muslims, in this case
Westerners. Bring back the fire.
Bring back the
fire and
and the rush.
and the righteous name.